Most people know that a balanced diet and regular exercise are very important.
However, most people do not know how to exercise properly.
Instead of concentrating on how to get the best results efficiently and effectively,...
...people usually rush through their workouts...
...or they make the same common workout mistakes.
Exercising the right way is important for people who are worried about their health and their appearance.
However, if someone is not working out properly, it is rare that he or she will see the results he or she wants.
Therefore, training experts have devised tips to teach people how to exercise correctly...
...in order to achieve the greatest health benefits.
If you want to achieve the best workout results,...
...here are a few helpful tips to bear in mind.
One of the most common workout mistakes is doing the same routine over and over again.
This does not challenge your muscles...
...and it can actually prevent muscles from growing and repairing themselves.
Instead of always sticking to the same old workout,...
...it is important to change your routine every six to eight weeks.
It is also important to add a variety of workouts to your routine...
...such as swimming, yoga, or biking to make sure your whole body stays fit.
This will help make your workouts more interesting...
...and benefit your health and muscle development as well.
Another mistake people tend to make is to work out too hard, too often.
Your body needs to rest between workouts. Otherwise, no progress will be made.
It is best to keep the number of hard workout routines to no more than two per week.
Then, for those who don't want to get off schedule by skipping a day,...
...shorter workouts of about twenty minutes can be used on other days.
For more variety in workouts,...
...you could also plan an easier routine for forty to sixty minutes...
...between days of shorter, more intense workouts.
Experts recommend, however, taking at least one day off completely each week,...
...especially after several hard workout days in a row.
In reality, no one is perfect.
However, if you want to make a difference in your overall health,...
...there are some things you can do.
Stretch before and after every workout.
Do not rush your routine and do not work out too little or too much.
Remember not to make these common workout mistakes...
...and always have fun while exercising!